[Music]
start practicing harder you guys can
really play
hi everybody i'm marinelle sub marin
began conducting
in 1980 she's currently the chief
conductor of the vienna radio symphony
orchestra
today i'll be breaking down clips from
movies and tv
about orchestras technique mr holland's
opus
[Music]
when he starts the piece it looks as
though it's going to be a very quiet
opening
certainly not in the drums
you really have to set up the drums in a
much bigger way
[Music]
another big issue i have with this clip
is that i can't imagine any student
orchestra
playing at this level
the high trumpets the horns
the articulation
this is way way way beyond a high school
orchestra
could possibly play
the character of mr holland he's
basically just
beating time it's a very robotic
approach
to conducting with both arms doing the
exact same thing
and this is one of the basic
conducting issues that we try to
discourage our students from doing we're
not here to impress each other
conducting
is all about separating your hands so
that you can create
two different worlds the right hand
controls the pulse
the beat and has to be in a pattern a
four pattern
two three four a three pattern one two
three or two pattern and the left hand
is all about emotion
about gesture about dynamics this is
getting louder this is getting softer
there's a lot that the musicians read
from our faces
but mostly it's working on this
independence of hands
which he doesn't exhibit whatsoever in
this clip
we know that this is a sort of a very
empowering
and emotional scene
[Music]
but from watching his gestures
we really wouldn't know that a little
error there
lingo amadeus come let's begin
a minor confrontation
the lingo used here is a combination of
two things one is the text for the
requiem mass
and this is from the latin text for the
mass and the section that they're
working on
is the confutates
[Music]
so that's actually the lyric that mozart
is composing at that moment yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes go on
boka may soto voce
write that down soto voce yes yes
when mozart asks salieri to please write
in
sota voce that's
an italian instruction that composers
use
to describe the quality of the sound
and soto voce means under voice
so it's almost like whispering and
yes and underneath just violins
arpeggios
or the other term arpeggio that's when
the orchestration outlines
the triads outlines the notes
descending scale in eighth notes and
then back to the astanato again and
that's it
that's an arpeggio listen to me i don't
understand
listen when salieri says i don't
understand
i don't think that's realistic he would
have definitely understood i don't
understand
the director is trying to point out how
advanced mozart was yes yes yes yes yes
go on
i absolutely love this movie it's
historically not
100 accurate it's not to be believed but
it so captures the immense
talent of mozart thank you and the sense
that
he knew what he wanted to write and he
could just put it right into the full
score
just out of his head as if he were just
taking dictation
music already finished in his head
motivation whiplash
[Music]
were you rushing or were you dragging
you know i can
barely discern that he's rushing
ever so slightly
but you know often musicians they need a
little bit of
runway to get into the groove of a piece
especially young musicians
the teacher has absolutely no tolerance
for any kind of imperfection
start counting five six seven four damn
it look at me
one two three four one two
i think this kind of approach you know
where you break
where a teacher breaks a student and
then
re-mold them and rebuild them in in kind
of in their image
it's a very self-centered narcissistic
way of teaching
[Music]
it can be effective because it's
terrifying
but i don't think people learn out of
fear
start practicing harder neiman
whiplash bar 125.
the music business is highly competitive
it's not unusual in a student setting
to have competitions for the first chair
so you know this can be either an
extremely
productive and positive experience or it
can be
like it is in whiplash it can be a
competition
almost to the death why are you still
sitting there get the [ __ ] out
novice conductor mr bean
when i start the opening of beethoven's
fifth symphony
always have to be very careful not to
make a gesture before
that opening gesture because somebody
will play
and that's what's so cute about this it
makes me laugh out loud
he just moves the baton and he gets a
cord
[Music]
as a first time conductor i definitely
give him high marks
he understands the idea of body language
and response
that's what comes across so clearly in
this little clip
conducting a choir sister act
[Music]
first of all i have to say i love her
enthusiasm
[Music]
you'll notice in this clip and and it's
quite realistic that
whoopi doesn't use any baton she uses
just her hands
this is quite typical of choir
conductors it's more about
dictating what's happening and really
describing it with your
with both hands as opposed to very
elaborate patterns
and trying to give cues to everyone
this is a much more visceral kind of
approach to conducting and
i find that with choirs it really works
well
[Music]
i absolutely adore whoopi goldberg i
think she's
phenomenal in this role we can rock this
place
there's so much heart in it and i think
as a conductor that's really what we're
trying to do
we're trying to inspire others to be the
best they can be
that's our goal
[Music]
rehearsal unorthodox
okay the thing that i love about this
clip
is that the orchestra is really playing
the dvorak string serenade
the level that they're playing at is a
level that would be consistent with a
student orchestra
[Music]
dasia where are you today
i was playing the wrong boys that's not
exactly
what a young violinist would say they
would say i was
on the wrong bow or i was doing the
wrong bowings in essence what it means
is that someone is out of sync where are
you today
when one player in a section is going in
opposition it can really upset the
look of the section and the ensemble too
because string sections are accustomed
to doing the same bowings
at the same time
what we're seeing is the main character
trying to
imagine herself in this setting
but what i loved about this series is
that
it didn't pretend to
suddenly make a virtuoso out of someone
who couldn't possibly have achieved that
level yet
there are singers who are born with
beautiful voices but
no one comes out of brooklyn after a few
lessons on the piano ready to play the
philharmonie
instead it was much more realistic about
whether she could get into this
conservatory
and if so on what instrument not on the
piano not ever i'm sorry
imitation copying beethoven
we see the premiere of beethoven's final
symphony
his monumental ninth symphony
and by this time in his life he was
almost entirely deaf
[Music]
he's following the conducting of
the actress in front of him
and really imitating her gestures
because of course he can't hear the
orchestra
and can't react to it
[Music]
it's not an easy thing to do to do the
exact
opposite of what you normally do i
actually have played in an
orchestra where someone who didn't read
music was taught to conduct in this way
it was a very odd thing to
experience but it was quite fascinating
in a way
to see this kind of symbiotic conducting
[Music]
experience
the premiere of beethoven's ninth
symphony
could not have possibly sounded this
good the piece was
incredibly hard for the orchestra of
that day they only had one day of
rehearsal
i want to say while i enjoy this clip so
much i think that the playing is
far too good you must experience these
works of mine
conducting dancers mozart in the jungle
[Music]
we don't even know where this music is
coming from
[Music]
but this whole scene plays into this
maestro mythology you know the idea of
the conductor
as this magician this inaccessible
and talented creature it's very
mysterious
that somehow can conjure up music from
thin air
i mean of course i don't believe this
for a second
this is not really an instance
of dancers reacting to the conductor
because
they clearly have their own choreography
and their own movements
i think this whole series mozart in the
jungle
has been absolutely wonderful for
classical music in terms of
bringing it into our homes and
demystifying it but
it also is a bit unrealistic
relationships meeting venus members of
the orchestra work according to a
schedule
agreed between the union and the
management so it was pointless to have a
real soul yesterday
and it will be equally pointless to talk
about my ideas
today i think this is a fascinating clip
because it really gives you some
insight into the hierarchy of you know
who's who's really in charge i beg you
to let me work please
when we see conductors with orchestras
they are
clearly you know in the alpha role but
when we see conductors
in the opera house the conductor has to
contend
of course with the musicians will you be
here
i don't know i haven't looked that much
have you you have a diva
like glenn close cory may i introduce to
you maestro santo
you have to deal with that the conductor
is definitely on the bottom
of this hierarchy
that is not something that would
normally happen
the soloist speaks with the conductor
and says what's our plan what shall we
do and then the conductor would ask the
orchestra please let's turn to this arya
i have great empathy for the character
santos
the conductor in this clip we didn't
agree to anything maya's maestro
we weren't even here yesterday there
have been situations that i've been in
where oh people don't show up or
someone's ill and i've gone to an upper
performance and
i have a different cast in the evening
from what i had at the rehearsal
you have to somehow manage all of these
catastrophes do you see what i have to
put up with all the time
can you shut them up switching genres
school of rock
in this scene jack black discovers that
his students
are really proficient at classical music
you guys can really play why didn't
anyone
tell me now he wants to introduce them
to rock music
and make a really fantastic band one
two three four
yes classical musicians that go into
rock
i think have a really fun time letting
loose
i think when rock musicians come over to
classical music sometimes they're
shocked by the rigidity of this
style of music nothing could be harder
what i absolutely
love about this scene and about this
whole movie is
jack black's enthusiasm
[Music]
he's just dying to share his passion
with us
yes all right let's go
i think that is the number one criteria
for being a conductor is to want
and really insist on sharing one's
passion for the music
it's really about capturing the groove
for everything
that's ultimately the conductor's main
job
is capturing that groove so i love it
all right
practice the orchestra rehearsal
[Music]
it's clear that no one's playing an
instrument
their bows are going all which ways
they're playing at different times
he's conducting on the wrong beat at the
bar so there's a sense of
[Music]
chaos
when the conductor is speaking while
you're playing you can't hear what he's
saying
or she is saying
i've certainly never had musicians
disrobe down to the skin
in rehearsals
he's trying to catch someone
out and really reprimand them in front
of the entire orchestra
which i think is is inappropriate under
any circumstance
i think there's no turning back for this
conductor at this point
the point of this film is the
individual characters and it's the idea
of the individual revolting
against the establishment which is
represented by the conductor
this isn't a highly political film and
it's about
much more than an orchestra rehearsal
[Applause]
wrong note hannibal red dragon
and hannibal goes to the concert hall
and listens to a performance of
mendelson's midsummer night's dream
[Music]
and he notices a few problems in the
orchestra
people make mistakes and i think it's
important as the conductor to
notice it of course but
how the conductor reacts can really
impact
the the entire piece from there on
[Music]
as soon as you start to kind of
reprimand
with your face all the musicians start
to go down this path
it can be like a domino effect that
everyone starts playing wrong notes or
everyone starts having errors
i think if i were a musician in the
orchestra and i looked out and i saw
hannibal sitting in the audience i would
have a bad day and play wrong
notes too conclusion this was a
wonderful
experience to look at all of these clips
and analyze them
it made me realize what a metaphor
music is and and how much we connect
with it on so many levels